e
e e
okay good morning
everyone all right so uh for our last
day as a committee for
the 23 24
session um we only have what 33 30 some
bills to have to get through here but
since we all know what we're going to do
here um my biggest interest in each one
we get is who's going to be willing to
write the committee report and I'm
hoping I get volunteers because I hate
to have to write them
all so
could just be simply that the committee
said yeah you say the committee is voted
because the language of the bill in its
current form is not workable and that uh
would and if you want to if you want to
say something positive to if you really
kind of wanted the bill the pass you can
say that uh that you can find an issue
where you think we have some agreement
on what we could agree on and say if the
bill focusing on that issue then then uh
if it you know it's could be
reintroduced uh it should be narrowed
just simply say it should be narrowed
and representative Spears already sent
me her too and she did a wonderful
job I sent you m and I sent yes oh it's
all
wonderful it's all
wonderful
okay all right start out with House Bill
73 relative to repair of Home Appliances
who would like to write the committee
report so much for for my
plea okay representative
Cole All Right Moves uh not recommended
for future legislation is there any
discussion on the
motion seeing
none
call Representative Ammon
yes pus
yes
yes yes
yes yes yes solivan
yes oh yes
and stand by she's counting 15 15 is yay
Zer okay
all right the motion passes
um how many people are you in the room
oh I didn't vote oh rep chairman hunt
16 thanks for catching
us okay all right moving on uh so I've
just been told that um the house clerk
has has an even better uh blurb that
excuse me committee report say simply
says was the committee was unable to
reach a consensus on whether to
recommend further legislation or not
period so so if someone who is willing
to volunteer to make the motion you can
default to that language that sends if
you
like
yeah okay good was
that was that for
7 what what you want to come over here
and tell me what
okay all right moving on to the next one
all right 513 relative to uh
affordability and safety of clinician
administered drugs I don't even remember
this bill okay I remember it okay you
want to make the motion then sure since
I I sponsored it oh now we know remember
all right
represent uh I guess I should be looking
for a second representative
pusk so and the last one you can you can
put in pusk for the
okay uh so uh the motion is not
recommended for future legislation any
discussion on the motion seeing none the
clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pus yes
yes yes
M
yes
pelli
yes Bon
Walsh
yes CL yes m m yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan yes grassy
yes here and chairman hunt yes 16 Z okay
motion uh on to the next one uh
how's yeah I don't think we have a
consent Cal I think just a regular it's
only one calendar
so okay all right uh House Bill 225
relative prohibiting the use of currency
that could be detrimental to privacy
rights representative Ammon right so
she's passing
out motion is not recommended for future
legislation and representative Emmons
recognized to speak to his motion uh
thank you Mr chair we did do a a
subcommittee uh interim study
subcommittee on this this uh what car's
passing out here is uh good for
Christmas holiday
reading but it's a it's a it's a
synopsis of uh testimony that we had in
the subcommittee this this issue will
come up again next year so it's good to
kind of get familiar with it uh the uh
the guest that we had with the
permission of the chair was Michael
Anthony he's a policy Analyst at the KO
Institute Center for monetary and
Financial
Alternatives so he had some pretty
balanced testimony and that's what those
three pages
are and then uh our subcommittee report
is being passed out that that will be my
blurb and uh not recommended for future
legislation okay any discussion on the
motion uh seeing none the clerk will
call the role who me the motion Ammon
and two SEC
representative Ammon yes pus yes host
yes Cole yes
M yes pelli yes ja
yes yes baros yes CL yes M yes Gibbs yes
Sullivan yes spear yes grassy yes and
chairman Hub yes Z
okay on to the next one uh House Bill
303 relative to insurance coverage for
paying Management
Services you would like
to write the committee
report
anybody did did this one become overcome
by a another Committee in another group
that was looking into this they were
looking at another yeah the the Health
and Human Services committee was also
looking into this and then and we
haven't seen the results of that so
we're assume that that that that
committee is appropriate to make the
right decision for this right if you
want me to write that part up I'll write
it up okay
perfect not recommended for future
legislation representative Speer second
by representative pusc
representative Ammon yes pusk yes poost
yes yes M yes melli yes taxton yes Walsh
yes baros
yes CL yes M yes Gibbs yes fear yes
Sullivan yes grassy yes and Sham hun
yes
okay uh next is House Bill 242 relative
to Banning past and food
packaging okay
cool okay it's already been dealt with
we dealt with it in our in our bill that
we did pass so
yes anything more than that yeah we've
already we've dealt with this one and
the next issue the two of them we dealt
with with a separate legislation that
the governor did not veto and is now on
its way to becoming
law all right representative spear
second by representative
Cole that well we can only do one time
so yes you can you
can but yes both of them had the same
answer which is both of these issues
were addressed we kept them in the
committee but be because we weren't sure
what was going to happen with the one
that we did pass the P Bill we did
pass okay any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role this this is right now we're
doing not recommended
yes that's your default check
yes representative Ammon yes pus yes
post yes Co yes M yes pelli
yes yes Walsh yes fos yes clerk yes maer
yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes
chairman hun yes yes
okay House Bill
465 restricting the use
of I don't can't
say substances and other consumer past
type stuff
okay so that goes with the other ones
representative spear sing by
representative Cole moves not
recommended for future legislation is
there any discussion on the motion
seeing none me a minute see
the clerk will call the role when she's
ready I guess I got to do 544
representative Ammon yes pusk yes po yes
Cole yes M yes Chell yes taxton yes
Walsh yes Barrow
yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes Pier yes
Sullivan yes grassie yes chairman hunt
yes 16 Z
okay moving on uh House Bill
544 legalizing cannabis for retail sale
who would like to make that motion
Walsh you want to make that
motion okay represent sell is going to
Second
it any discussion on the
motion nope don't need to
okay clerk will call the call the role
of not recommended for future
legislation
he representative
Ammon
yes pus yes post yes Cole yes M yes
pelli yes taxton yes Walsh yes baros yes
clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan yes grassie yes chairman hun
yes 16 Z okay
House Bill
117 relative to creating a committee to
study the protection of business
operators against requests to
accommodate customers with fraudulent or
untrained service
animals
okay Cole you want to do that
one is not recommended for future
legislation any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role so um Cole oh Cole and
pusc representative Ammon yes pus yes
Cole
yes po
yes yes pachelli yes axon yes Walsh yes
baros yes Clark yes M yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes
grassie yes and chairman H
yes
okay uh 1183 relative prohibiting the
sale of agricultural land and land
essential to critical Industries to
China Mr W would like to make Mr
chairman we have another meeting on this
coming up we have a study committee so
therefore this bill is you know us
taking action is meaningless because
there is a study
committee representa Walsh would like to
write
it because she wants to get on the good
side of the senator
bed okay what okay not recommend it for
future
legislation and this is
1183 wsh in in
spe's put it in
anyway representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes M yes pachelli yes
dton yes
yes barrows yes clerk yes M yes
Gibbs
yes Pier yes Sullivan yes grassy yes
hunt yes
chairman okay 16 is zip moving on uh
house spill 1207 relative single use
disposable plastic food wear accessories
anyone I'll do it okay all right
Amon and
pus
yeah
am okay okay the motion is uh not
recommended for future legisl any
discussion on the motion seeing none the
clerk will call the
role when she's ready representative
Amon yesus yes poost yes Cole yes M
yesi yes yes Walsh yes Burrows
yes
B yes M yes Gibbs yes spear
yes yes grass yes
yes
okay R House Bill 1225 relative to
prescription drug affordability board
conflicts of
interest oh
brelli second in by representative pusk
any discussion on the motion of not
recommending for future
legislation see none the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli
yes Walsh yes
Barrow clerk yes Mair yes Gibbs yes
Speer yes Sullivan yes grassy yes
chairman hun
yes okay next up is 1232 prohibiting the
state or local governments from using
Central Bank digital currency
representative Ammon moves not
recommended for future
legislation any discussion on the motion
I'll just comment that the the pages
that I passed out from the K Institute
apply to this subject area too so if you
want to read up on it uh but my motion
is not recommended okay
question question okay uh this one is
specifically at the holesale level and
the other one is more at the retail
level so they're not really quite the
same does that make any difference to
your
discussion not for today's purposes no
okay it's too much detail same yeah we
don't want to get in the weeds today
yeah the KO this covers both retail and
wholesal okay okay just
just okay are you seconding the motion
sure
okay recommendation is not not
recommended representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yes yes pelli yes
taxon yes Walsh yes Barrow yes Clark yes
maer yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
yes grassy yes chman hun yes
Z okay next up uh House Bill 1306
relative to special assessment for
Capital Improvements in
Condominiums who's our who's our condo
person R Cole
great seconded by representative pusk
not recommended for future
legislation is there any discussion on
the
motion seeing
none the clerk will call the role of not
recommend
Ed representative Ammon yesus yes poost
yes Co yes M yes pachelli yes daxon yes
Walsh yes Burrows
yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
solivan yes grassy yes chairman hun yes
16 Z
okay and 1374 relative to liing licenses
for restaurants representative Solomon
seconded by representative pusc is not
recommended for future
legislation is there any discussion on
the
motion seeing
none kurk will call the rooll
representative am yes Fus yes post yes
Cole yes H yes belli yes taxton yes
Walsh yes fos yes clerk
yes M kid yes spear yes Sullivan yes
rassie yes chairman hunt yes
okay next up uh House Bill 1395 relative
to home heating oil and propane
contracts
Cool Cole second
by for two Cole for
two is there any discussion on the
motion
seeing
none Kur clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes melli yes Faxton
yes Walsh yes blos yes cler yes Mair
yes Gibbs yes beer yes Sullivan yes
Grassi yes and chairman hunt yes
okay you want to do this one next
one okay next bill
HB 1444 relative to local regulation of
digital
Mining and representative Ammon second
by representative pusk not recommended
for future
legislation is there any discussion on
the
motion seeing
none representative Ammon yes pus yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes baros yes Clark yes M yes
Gibs yes spear here yes Sullivan yes
grassy yes chamman hunt yes
okay next up uh House Bill 1571 relative
to requiring insurance coverage for
glucose
monitoring no no oh oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I I was jumping ahead on that one
okay HB
1507 you want to do that one yes okay
pelli any discussion on the motion of
not recommended for future legislation
on
1507 seeing
none clerk will call the
vote representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes m yes pelli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes fos yes cler yes M yes
Gibbs
yes spear yes suvan grassy yes Jam hunt
yes Z okay now I'll spill 1571 relative
requiring insurance coverage for glucose
monitoring devices is for people with
diabetes representative spear second by
representative pusk not recommended for
future
legislation it is that's what I thought
going to be no you're saying you're
gonna say it's not recommended future
legislation but going the bill if
someone wants to introduce this bill
next year what you're going to what
they're going to what you're
recommending no that's that's fine yeah
we we'll get it updated what I don't
understand because it's really going to
be a different bill that's going to be
introduced it's going to be a new bill
it's not going to be this
bill no we're we're saying not
recommended because we the bill in its
current form is not recommended but that
we're recommending that if someone were
to other words that that language of
recommending is in the blurb of saying
if somebody were to put this bill
in represent you don't like it that way
I I I I disagree I think what we're
saying here is that it's recommended for
further legislation it doesn't have to
be the exact wording of the bill right
it can be a different bill but what
we're recommending is that they're we're
we're basically putting our support
again behind anyone who was who wants to
resubmit this bill but we're
recommending it for future legislation
and and I think that it says that that
we encourage someone to come forward
with a bill doesn't require us to do any
more rather than not requiring it and if
if you if if you're intending to have a
motion to say that this is not
recommended I will vote no right okay
well that's that's fine we can do that
but the my intent was always that to is
is not to have the next legislature who
takes this bill come in and have to go
back and look and see what we did or
what we thought or where we were at it
but that they they have have that as as
something that the subcommittee can work
with but that at the end of the day that
bill as is being introduced will be the
new new bill it'll be a new subject what
they will do Mr chairman they will look
back at what we did here in this
legislation and our recommendation that
we encourage further legislation right
so and I think if we vote no they would
look back at this committee saying that
well the committee didn't think it was
important or think this was a good
enough bill so therefore maybe we
shouldn't introduce something or maybe
people will look at this and saying we
shouldn't support this in the future
where say if we say yes it is
recommended for future legislation we're
supporting efforts to move forward and
people going to look back that this
committee supports this effort and I
think that's what the seemed to be that
we supported this effort and we support
it in the future and we want to see it
come back voting no would be contrary to
that y I agree me voting saying not
recommended would be contrary all right
representative
m m Mr chairman can I ask you just a
question I thought that we're discussing
the bill in its basically exact current
form so if we supported this
bill in let me just let me just me just
finish if that's what I said my
understanding is if we supported this
bill in its current form like I'm I'm
going to speak for my own bill because I
would have liked to have seen it pass
too and I'm writing a blurb saying it's
not recommended for future legislation
because I understood through the process
and aerm
study that it's not like there were
enough issues with it and so I wrote the
blur not recommended for my own bill
that it's not recommended for future
legislation however I think there's
enough issues with it you know safety
and affordability of of uh prescription
drugs I think we all think that we ought
to study you know we ought to address
the issue of affordability and pricing
of prescription drugs I think that's
very bipartisan everybody agrees that
drugs are expensive and we should look
at those issues so so we should continue
to look at those issues but it wasn't
that bill and I think it's we pretty we
also pretty much agree in the case of
this one um coverage for glucometer
monitoring I hear it all the time I use
it myself we ought to look at it but if
somebody brought back this this bill
unamended this language we wouldn't
recommend it because we didn't before or
we would have passed it except that
we're writing in here why what needs to
change what yes agreed and that's and
that's good we we should Pro I believe I
believe we should probably do that but
this
bill this bill and it is a little bit of
semantics but this bill is not
recommended and like my own bill 5 513 I
think it was I'm not
recommending so we're not recommending
any of these bills then what's the words
future legislation mean okay so what I
what I'm saying to you right that we
used to
have not recom mended recommended or
recommended with
Amendment they took that motion away
from
us okay under the rules that motion was
taken away so here's the point the point
being is to say is would we really
recommend a bill that it it doesn't
matter whether you're pre-diabetic or
diabetic or not diabetic at all that we
are going to do a health insurance
mandate then anybody can get one of
these glut close monitoring things well
no okay so that's why I will let you
speak I'll let you speak okay so that's
why the the issue is that what I thought
I sent out in my email to everybody is
all B bills are not recommended but that
if you really do want the issue if you
really do want that bill that you really
like the issue then I wanted you to
write the blurb and say that even though
the committee is not recommending
legislation we think that a bill that
says this is does that then that would
that that's your recommendation but
you're writing that recommendation in
the committee report as a recommendation
for the future legislature the future
committee the for future sponsor so my
question is do I have to change what do
I change here I'll worry about
that okay then are you willing to make
the motion not for legislation knowing
that your blurb is not going to be
changed too much yeah I'll vote for that
okay too much okay so anybody else would
like to represent
a I mean is it possible to say something
like not recommended with its current
wording but unfortunately we need yes
you could write that that's exactly in
the blur exactly but not but not in the
you can't write cuz they took that
recommendation got it it's not
recommended in as it's didn't that you
know that but that you know that uh the
committee absolutely uh has been working
and thinking about this issue and if you
narrow it down and to what you would
wrote in your blurb you know narrowing
it down then you know then yeah as long
if if you're willing to just make a
change to the to the top part uh not
recommended then and if you leave the
rest of it the way it is then I'm fine
with that that's what that's what I plan
to do I guess I I missed that when I at
the top it was the capital letters it
was in
caps maybe that's why I didn't read
it I don't like it when anybody's
yelling at me so I I didn't read the
blur the uh report but for clarification
even though we support the concept the
bill in its current form is what we're
saying that we
want worked on at a future point so the
bill could be improved exactly and
that's what your write up will refle
even though we support it in concept you
don't pass Concepts you pass bills and
laws thank
you put your mic on M it says for future
legislation so you know I got a little
bit
lost somebody submitted right within the
time period in three weeks put your mic
on please be already filed no yeah it's
the Bill's already in yeah it's already
already been filed Okay so you okay
represent
grasson okay represent
Gibs thank you Mr chairman so just for
clarity this is a purely technical
recommendation that we don't recommend
this particular bill with this
particular wording correct but it's not
a statement that this is unimportant or
that we don't like the idea only that we
don't want to go forward with this
particular wording um and the person
writing the blurb could include
something about the importance of the
concept exactly thank you should I read
my blur don't know it's all right okay
because I don't like why do we even have
a session if
we're often wonder that because of the
blurs that are going to go out going to
clarify our motion uh my thinking was
that we retain the bill for the purpose
so that we can talk about it and we can
think about it so that when it does come
time to write those committee reports
the these committee reports that we can
state in them what what the issues were
of what was wrong with this this one and
what we think should occur in any future
legislation if we voted um to recommend
couldn't the blurb say the same
thing or the report it could it could
say it could yes you you well you say is
we recommend it but boy it need to be
amended okay no I was trying to keep it
simple and just say at this point this
bill in its current form and here's the
reason why we don't recommend it should
I read the reason and and you state the
reasons like you know it was to should I
read them sure why don't you read the
blur excuse me this bill requires Health
carriers to cover the cost of continuous
glucose monitoring equipment for anyone
with any type of diabetes or
hypoglycemia the bill includes
Provisions detailing the requirements
for qualifications caps on out of pocket
expenses and coverage under Medicaid as
it exists the bill is too broad in scope
with no way to bound the cost it is
recommended that the bill be Rewritten
to only include persons diagnosed with
type 2 diabetes on therapies other than
insulin glucose monitoring is already
provided for those on insulin and
covered fully under fully insured plans
in the New Hampshire large and small
group markets requirements for Medicaid
recipients should be handled in a
separate bill caps should be eliminated
data shows that caps often drive up cost
of medical devices paid for insurance
carriers Based on data received from the
insurance department across type 1
diabetes there is very little C sharing
with respect to continuous glucose
monitoring equipment again based on the
findings from data received on type 1
patients presented by the insurance
department and their assumptions
regarding the number of type two
patients willing to accept such
monitoring equipment the expected impact
to insurance cost would be fairly low
and I have the detailed numbers if
anybody cares however these costs would
be mitigated by a reduction in the
severe often critical outcomes of
diabetes on patients who do not
correctly monitor their glucose
levels I approve that that thank
you so now we are going to recommend no
we're not recommending for future
legislation but she's TI she's in there
what we recommend them to do the
Comm I hear you finally something we
fight about is there any more discussion
on the motion of not recommended for
future legislation who second pus uh
yeah
we yeah pusk is the second
okay any more discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pus yes o
yes PA yesil yes belli
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes clerk
no m
yeah Gibbs
yes Bear yes
Sullivan grassy
no chairman HUD yes
okay
yeah
okay all right uh House Bill 1582
relative to allowing for the consumption
of alcohol in artist performances areas
representative pusk recommends uh not
recommends for future
legislation and second well you want to
yeah this we already took it up in a
different Bill we actually did pass it
this is an
easy okay
so you want you want to write a
blurb you got it okay all
right all right representative
Sullivan I'll second second
representative pday
okay not recommended for future
legislation any more discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes
taxton yes Walsh yes baros yes clerk yes
M yes
Gibbs Gibbs sorry uh yes Feer yes
Sullivan yes grassy yes chairman Hut
yes okay uh House Bill
1621 representative pus pusk seconded by
representative
Sol requiring Liquor Commission
distribute certain information in liquor
stores not recommended for future
legislation
any discussion on the motion this
is somebody else they are going in well
in this case The Liquor Commission just
went ahead and put TV sets and and you
get when you walk in they're going to
advise you that you know yeah it's
already being done seen it
once but I know there saying isation is
not necessary not necessary right
right well well represented for
two but thank you for
volunteering
okay
okay next up uh house over we got vote
on what the heck
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes M yesi yes Aon yes Walsh
yes fos yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes
Spar yes Sullivan yes grassy yes jamman
hunt yes 16 Z
okay next up is House Bill 1636 relative
to creating the New Hampshire container
deposit refund recycle and reuse
system any
volunteers re sen Gibbs you want to
write the committee report I'm not
recommended for future
legislation
okay but you can write in support she
could write in it that you know that if
the way if they could do something to
address some of the issues that are in
that
bill you know that that why we're not
we're not recommending it because it's
you know way it's written but if she
could say in it that if the bill did
this or that you know then then would
there would be more sympathy for it
represent basically I'd be saying that
we're not recommending it because the
system in the bill was overly
complex and that if another bill with
the same purpose were to be brought
forward that could be recommended okay
there you
go okay second by represent
pusc any discussion on the motion seeing
none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon
yes J yes post yes
yes M yes pelli yes Aon yes Walsh yes
fos yes cler yes M yes
Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan grassy yes chairman hun yes 16
Z
okay moving on house spill 1645
establishing a condominium dispute
resolution board representative Burrow's
moves not recommended for future
legislation and is recognized to speak
to her
motion
um we're not going to recommend this for
future recommendation but as we are
going to be looking at a resolution
board for manufactured housing um we
will be looking to see if there's
anything that we can do in this regards
yep okay represent two second
[Music]
it okay is the motion
clear c will call the rooll
representative Ammon yesus yes poost yes
Cole yes M yes pelli yes Daxton yes
Walsh yes burrow yes clerk yes mle yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes Rassy
yes hunt yes 16
Z okay motion carries
1674 relative to establishing the
Hampshire legal tender act and
establishing a state bullion
depository this is yours right yeah
representa Ammon moves not recommended
for future legislation and recognized to
speak to his motion thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to uh pause here um I put
this bill in for state senator Jim
forsight and I just wanted to you know
kind of underscore that he passed away
uh you know while this bill was uh being
worked on and uh he was a he was
a uh New Hampshire was lucky to have him
as a senator and uh I just wanted
to just mention that um my blurb is uh
you should have a copy of it from the
subcommittee report so that's what I'll
be submitting thank
you any other discussion on the motion
of not recommended for future
legislation
see none the clerk will call the role
representative Ammon
yes post yesus yes Co yes the yes belli
yes Maxton yes Walsh yes fose yes clerk
yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
yes grassy yes hunt yes chairman h
160 okay uh House Bill 1702 relative to
the oversight of Liquor Commission
funding and repealing the Liquor
Commission fund I move representative
pusc
second by representative hunt can I
speak to this for a minute you can speak
to your motion of not recommended for
future leg thank you Mr chair it I
definitely recommend that this is not
ready for any further action and be put
in a hole and filled with six foot of
dirt thank
[Laughter]
you okay I I'd like to make a comment as
as as well um not recommended I agree
with but um there there was testimony
early on
um in the session regarding the timely
manner of the funds being um given back
to the state right and that was solved
in a different Bill okay that issue was
solved great
thanks okay any other discussion on the
motion the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pus yes
post yes Co yes
yes belli yes Faxton yes Walsh yes
Barrow yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes
beer yes Sullivan yes grassy yes
chairman hunt yes 16
Z all right we get through the house
bills now we do the Senate
bills Senate Bill 97 relative to the use
of animals in product testing all I'll
take what's that I I could speak to that
you could not recommended for future
legislation not recommended for future
legislation however um we will be
reviewing some of the recommendations of
the um Humane Society and Dartmouth
College uh going forward for potential
legislation okay I'd like to second that
second representative
yes okay
is the question clear the clerk will
call the
role representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes belli
yes taxton yes Walsh bur
yes CLK yes M yes Gibbs yes beer yes
Sullivan grassy yes Cam hunt yes did
I representative taxon did I not give
you a chance to respond I said yes no I
know I have that but I thought I went on
to the next before he didn't have his
mic on he was very quiet okay no we're
good just wanted to
apologize all right 16 Z
okay Senate Bill 332 limiting red
disclosures of consumer reports
requested in connection with a credit
transaction involving an extension of
credit secured by real
estate
okay represent
faction okay
uh
pus all right any discussion on the
Motions see none the clerk will call the
role of inexp to legisl not excuse me
not recommended fut I really G to get
myself in trouble representative Ammon
yes pusk yes post yes Cole
yes yes belli Yes jaon Yes W yes baros
yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Elan grassy yes chairman hunt yes 16
[Music]
Z okay Senate Bill 353 relative
insurance coverage for autism spectrum
disorder and down syndrome
representative
spear recommends not recommended for
future legislation but has
a has a committee report maybe you want
to read your committee report this bill
seeks to add Down syndrome to the list
of biologically based mental illnesses
listed in RSA 4 uh 17e in order to gain
access to certain behavioral therapies
however down syndrome itself is not a
mental disorder and I think that needs
to be very clear it is a genetic
condition that includes intellectual
disability Down syndrome individuals
have some form of autis uh excuse me
down syndrome individuals can certainly
have accompanying mental disorders for
example it is estimated that
approximately 20% also have some form of
autism spectrum disorder based on
discussions with medical director of the
largest health insurance provider and
the fully insured Market in New
Hampshire those Down syndrome patients
diagnosed with exhibiting symptoms of
autism and who are correctly coded as
such by their doctor have full access to
applicable therapies several
organizations including the New
Hampshire insurance department were
asked if there were any records of
complaints or individuals being turned
down for treatment while one person did
come forward they were recovered under a
self-insured plan over which the
legislature has no control the concern
is that the those patients that may need
help are not seeking it and while 353 is
problematic as written a better written
Bill accompanied by actionable data
could be evaluated in the future well
done
perfect well done thank you thank you
she should be
Governor I write specs for a living I
know how to do
this all right is the motion cleared the
clerk will call the role representative
an yes pusk yes post yes Co yes yesi
yesx yes Walsh yes Barrow yes clerk yes
M yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
grassie yes chairman hunt yes 16
Z okay Senate Bill
365 relative to the sail or use of
lithium ion batteries for electric
bicycles SC scooters personal Electric
Mobility
devices you do this one key
question right I have a question we
received amendments for this that we
didn't seem to vote
on uh we we never in terms of when we
send it to interim study right there was
there was still because we were trying
to address the
European numbers and and they did submit
an amendment with that right so but
we're so we would ex you write that in
the blur that we would expect if this
bill would to come back next year that
they would have that in it all
right okay representative
spear any more discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role
representative Ammon yes pus yes post
yes Cole yes M yes melli yes dton yes
Walsh yes Burrows yes clerk yes M yes
Gibbs yes Sullivan yes beer yes grassy
yes chairman hunt yes
Z
okay next Senate Bill 477 relative
establishing commission to review and
make recommendations regarding
Technology based startup
businesses support from the state of New
Hampshire okay represent
Ammon second by representative pusc
is there any discussion on the
motion I think the uh the New Hampshire
New Hampshire does have a fund uh that
supports uh entrepreneurs um in this
field so we don't need future
legislation and I also want to um just
comment we didn't have any followup or
any representation um from the people
that presented this bill you know in
subcommittee or exec committee so who in
the public Hearing in the public hearing
it was um well I don't know what the SP
the sponsor we had Scott mer I got cut
off my sponsor list for Senate bills
yeah me
too uh let's see 477 right yeah
individuals speaking on the bill um were
here to present the bill um as well as
the sponsor and then they didn't I think
they got the sense that we weren't too
excited on it
yeah uh Senator Ganon is the prime SP
Ganon yeah interesting well he'll be
back
so okay he'll be
back I don't know about that yeah when
do you give up your parking
space I don't have to give it up because
I never did
get he's he's looking at me
yeah
okay all right um any discussion on the
motion the clerk will call the role U
not recommended for future legislation
representative am yesus yes post yes
Cole
yes yes pelli yes baxton yes Walsh yes
baros yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes
spear yes
Sullivan grassy yes chairman hunt yes
16 okay uh Senate Bill 64 establishing
study committee on resident-owned
manufactured housing Park disputes and
oversight of resident-owned
manufactured housing Parks okay um this
particular bill is not being recommended
for future study
because
stud but however we are recommending um
future Le future legislation to explore
another number of options in conjunction
with um the
stakeholders any discussion on the
motion okay clerk will call the role of
not recommended for future
legislation Burrows and then pusi y
represent of Ammon yes pusk yes post yes
Cole yes the yes pelli yes taxton yes
Walsh yes Barrow yes cler
no M
no Gibbs yes
spear yes
Sullivan grassy
no chairman hun
yes 13 13 133 13
33 Okay Senate Bill 180 relative to
product labeling and information guide
requirements for cannabis products and
the prohibition of the sale of hemp
products containing certain levels of
THC so some of this stuff was addressed
by a different
bill and we like to write the blurb on
itbl
okay second by representative
pusc any discussion on the motion of not
recommended for future legislation
seeing none the clerk will call the
role representative Amon
yesk yes poost yes Cole yes M yes Chelly
yes Daxton yes Walsh yes Barrow yes
clerk yes maer yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan y grassy yes chamman hunt yes
Z okay motion
carries Senate Bill 2011 relative to the
resale of event tickets
I don't remember why this didn't
pass representative peros um I did some
research after the fact okay and um the
cons the consumer um protection laws
cover a lot of this already so they do
have protections that we were not
discussing at the
time you will write the blur sure thank
you Jane were you looking at Jane I
think you were no I was always I'm doing
enough writing right now do
okays
slash
pusc okay is the question clear
[Music]
we we have one more left so you should
have one more extra sheet
yeah okay this is
2011's right representative
Ammon pusk yes poost yes Cole yes M yes
melli yes yes Walsh yesos
CL yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
grassy
Sullivan chairman H
yes he was out of the room with the
question was put
so I did not noce my back was
turned 15 Z
okay all right
okay ready for the last
one last but not least Senate Bill 235
relative to service provided through a
primary care behavioral health
model representative M do is this one of
yours
no it's a Senate bill so you can't be a
prim not
yet does anybody remember what this bill
is
about you can write
the
behavioral I I'll write the
blur you finally got one I got
one do SI and this is not recommended
not recommended for future
legislation any discussion on the
motion
okay representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes po yes M yes pelli yes
zon
Walsh no out of the
room out of the room uh clerk yes Mair
yes Gibbs yes
spear
yes yes grassy yes Kevin Hut
yes okay
and with
that can I ask a question
yes we had
a we had a bill concerning
um buw Pub licenses you remember the U
yes Michael Timothy came in yes and we
got that passed it was HB
13 1380 I guess it was yes
they came back with a letter that
indicated the wrong one got passed
correct and I will be putting in the
bill in to correct that that's what I
wanted to know okay good so for now no
it's a nonissue now but it there was
there was some tension whether the
governor should veto the whole thing
which we didn't want them to do so we
the the the what actually ironically
what we passed pass is actually statute
and that we will we will amend it uh I
will I'll will amend it for next session
okay it's back to the compromise
language that it was worked out between
um the parties that were
involved representative Gibs when do you
need the um committee report um try to
get it done this
week okay thank you
please any any else representating
M thank you for an enjoyable term my
third with third with you separated by
20 some years as most of you know I will
not be returning so I enjoyed working
with all of you and hope to see you
again next year in a somewhat different
capacity God willing we'll know in about
three weeks there you go but I genuinely
appreciate it Mr chairman thank you so
much you're very welcome um before you
all leave please clean out your
drawers you have you have drawers in in
the back room here we're not worried
about it wasn't that kind of
day okay uh
and and then um also we we do have um
thank you uh to our
our committee assistant and our
committee researcher so uh any
contributions that you want to pay into
it will be greatly accepted and that the
clerk is handling that so you just want
to stop by here
and do your your part that would be
great I have gift certificates for the
two of them and some homemade grape
preserves for myself thank
you represented buros yes yeah I I want
to
second what um representative MCU said
um I really appreciate the chair for his
Good Humor for his fairness and I really
hope that next term we have people that
aren't going to muck up the nice
nonpartisanship that we've had for the
past two years because it's been it's
been great and um again please no no
crazy people thank
[Laughter]
you on that note
uh we are
adjourned um could I please have this
for being your clerk for two
years what you want to take my gav thank
you you have many
of
e for